the Norwegian Nobel Committee is
selected by the norwegian parliament
there are five members they serve
six-year terms they may be reelected
they reflect the balance of the parties
in Parliament they cannot be members of
the government or members of parliament
so they tend to be ex politicians or
they may not be that intimately involved
in politics at all but they are very
practical persons I was going to say men
but we actually have a majority of women
now on the committee they are practical
in the sense that they do not spend much
time on definitions of peace I am sure
that if we had had a committee of
academics we would be spending an awful
lot of time on the definition of peace
and I'm sure that we will be returning
it to it constantly to see if there was
a need for revisions and my Swedish
counterparts they were shocked when I
met them the first time and they said to
me you should have a committee of
academics in Norway like we do in Sweden
it was somewhat unclear to me how I who
was their secretary was to select the
members of the committee but they were
even more shocked when i told them i
vastly prefer a committee of politicians
what's needed to serve on the committee
is common sense and good political
judgment but of course indirectly
through the choices they committees have
indeed defined peace and I would suggest
to you that there are four main threads
running through our 100-year history and
I'm also suggesting that these will
indeed be the main lines or threads
running through
our next century because much may have
been accomplished along these four
dimensions but much much remains to be
done
you